[Music]
hi everyone thanks for joining me today
my name is Anand Shah and I'm the
product manager on GC marketplace so
before we get started I really want to
talk about who you guys are just in case
anyone here is going through certain I
Sandee crisis but more seriously I want
to make sure everyone here gets the most
out of this session this session is
going to be focused on GC admins looking
to really complement the GC offering
with all the awesome tools that our
third-party developers have built and so
quickly going over the agenda today
we're going to talk about picking the
right solution for your business and
what that process looks like and then
we're going to talk about how the GC
marketplace can help then we have two
awesome partners here smartsheet and
prosper works we're going to talk
through their GP marketplace apps and
how they can empower your business and
finally we'll leave some time for Q&A so
let's get into it let's talk about the
picking the right SAS solutions for your
business and how that process kind of
sucks right now
so I'm going to talk to you about a
business that I plan to open it's called
on ins beard wax corporation it doesn't
exist right now but I promise you I'm
going to open it when I retire it's
going to be awesome and the story of
owensboro ice Corporation reflects a lot
of the stories that we hear from
customers today on G suite quick context
we salt beard wax also I love this too
this image of designer produced because
it kind of looks more like me than my
original picture so we saw beard wax and
the employee our employees are currently
on G sweet you know they're using all
the creative tools on Dawg sheets Drive
they're able to collaborate and they're
able to communicate on Gmail and
hangouts and all that sort of things but
sales are skyrocketing we've done we've
run some ad campaigns to all the hipster
communities in Brooklyn and San
Francisco and everyone really wants to
sell their moustache and the sales are
going through the roof and with all
these increased sales our employees need
more tools we need tools to manage all
the sales and different leads we're
getting a lot of requests for bulk
orders of the beard
we're getting a lot of tickets from
customers you know good feedback on how
they're able to sell their beards and
mustaches but also some bad feedback on
all the rashes they're getting and we
want to make sure we get back to the
these customers promptly and finally we
want to manage all the different project
streams you know as we're updating the
website as we're developing new lines of
new lines of beer washes we're going to
make sure we can align the marketing and
the sales and all the sort of production
that goes into that and as CEO of honors
beer-wise corporation is a bit
overwhelming so let's even talk about
one of these use cases let's talk about
customer support and what sort of
factors go into picking the right
solution for customer support I'm going
to look at the price for all the
different tools available right which
ones which one is the cheapest or which
one is going to run me dry you know is
the tool secure you know if all these
tickets are coming in from customers how
do I make sure that this data won't be
leaked and that it won't show up on the
New York Times I want to make sure that
the tool that I pick works with our
company's existing solutions especially
with G suite I want to make sure that
the tool works well with Gmail that all
the files coming in don't aren't sort on
a separate server but are automatically
in Drive right and finally I want to
look across all the different sort of
players in this space see what other
admins are recommending who's really
innovating in this space and then I also
want to see what my end users are using
see if they're already already have
their own workflow already using any
tools or customer support and so across
all these factors it's again very
overwhelming so let's talk about GC
marketplace and sort of how it can help
so again you have me a CEO of Anand
Xerox Corporation and now I can go to
the G suite marketplace and sort of
search across all these different
categories of apps you know there's a
counting finance HR and legal and for
all the apps that are available on the
marketplace you can sort of see a
description of the app and also reviews
and ratings that other admins have left
so where we are at now the GC
marketplace has over 400 million
installs and we have a thousand
and there and what I want everyone to
take away sir from this session is that
jesusí marketplace makes it easy it
makes it easy to discover a new app it
makes it easy to deploy the app and it
makes it very easy to control the
different settings on the app so let's
get into discovery do you see are a
place makes it easy to discover new apps
I already mentioned a couple of these
things before you can search across
different categories you can do a
text-based query for the app that you're
looking for we have tons of ratings and
reviews and curated sections for
different apps out there you know we
have we have sections for what works
well with Drive or what works well what
apps are new and on the rise and if we
have a ton of different categories you
know across we have we have tools for
finance teams tools for schools and even
like if you think about what Islands B
or S corporation needed across customer
support project management and sales
tools we have all that sort of stuff on
the GC Marketplace and so now I want to
really get into the specifics like what
is an app on GC marketplace I like to
think about it in two different ways
so the one sort of category of apps are
add-ons these apps live inside the UI of
Google products as you can see on the
screenshot on the right we have an
add-on directly inside Google Docs
this is lucidchart and what it lets
users do is draw complex to our charts
whether it's flow diagrams or charts or
floor plans directly in Google Docs so
add-ons live inside of the Google
products and we have add-ons for dog
sheets forms and drive and you guys have
might have might have seen over the last
couple of days we've even announced up
coming out on support for Gmail slides
and hangouts chat the other category of
apps that you'll find on GC marketplace
are your standard sort of SAS web apps
you might go to prosper works calm
smarty calm and these sort of
third-party apps live on an external URL
however all of them for all of them you
can sign in with your Google account and
all of these apps also use a lot of
Google api's so
so you won't have to get a lot of them
will integrate automatically with drive
will automatically integrate with
calendar so you won't have to learn a
whole new system there so we talked
about discovery how you can find you
know your the app of your dreams on GP
marketplace and how and all the
different types of apps available let's
talk about how you can deploy an app
from GP marketplace so I like to think
of the deployment in sort of two ways if
you're an admin you can actually find
the app that you want to deploy and you
can deploy it to your entire company if
I want everyone in my company to use
this same project management tool I can
just say you know I want to deploy this
to everyone at my company or if it's a
tool that's specific for an organization
a sales tool you might only want to give
to your sales folks if it's a customer
support tool you might only want to give
it to your support team and you can
deploy it to a specific organization as
well finally you don't have to push out
a an app to everyone in your domain
rather you can let individuals come to
the GSB marketplace and just install
whatever they want and so I want a quick
show of hands how many folks here have
seen this scary OAuth screen how many of
you guys when you saw it
we're like I don't know if I should
accept it or like sort of freaked out
about it no offense to prosper works but
here you see prosper want to access your
drive and email and it's like I don't
know if I should allow it how many folks
have like sort of been like I don't know
if I should accept it ok a couple we
have sort of a technical group here but
what we've heard from a lot of users is
that the the end-user freaked out when
they see this OAuth 2 screen they're not
sure if they if they should give their
companies like sort of access to each
email or drive over to a third-party app
and what this what you see marketplace
does is or it transfers the burden from
the end user to the admin so now an
admin can accept the OAuth 2 grant and
bless it for their entire domain so that
when an end user starts using crosswords
they don't sort of see this screen and
lastly it's really easy to deploy an app
on GC marketplace let's say here we have
lucidchart
not only do they have a web app but they
have a sheet sat on a dog sat on and a
drive add-on rather than having to force
everyone to install each one separately
you can just deploy all these add-ons
and go all in on lucidchart with one
click and finally let's talk about the
different sort of tools you have for
control when end-users go to the GPO
marketplace they can explore all the
different types of apps that they want
to start using however we give admins
the ability to sort of whitelist certain
apps that they want that they want the
end-users to install so so they can have
you know security team audit different
apps or just all the rights are in apps
for people that have install finally you
can use GC Marketplace to also just
deploy a a custom app you know if you've
built an internal like project
management tool or internal sales tool
you know through GC marketplace to push
this out to your domain and so looking
forward we're going to have more add-on
types in the future Gmail slides
hangouts chat hangouts chat BOTS are all
coming soon we're gonna we're updating
our store UI going all material and
we're gonna have enhanced administrative
features so you can this is coming soon
but a lot of admins like maybe they
don't want their end users to start
using apps that have access to drive or
have access to Gmail so you can start
blacklisting and whitelisting different
a lot to scopes and I want to give a
quick shout out to our recommended
partners on G suite a lot of these folks
have made GP marketplace really really
successful and a lot of customers have
seen success using these partners apps
so I think a lot of them have boots on
the first floor so if you haven't had a
chance go check them out and with I just
want to recap GP marketplace makes it
easy to discover the apps that you want
to use at your company and easily deploy
it at your company and then finally just
control the settings around it and with
that I'm going to hand it off to Andy
lens from smartsheet
good afternoon thanks for coming out
today
I wanted to spend a little time
introducing smartsheet but then talk
about how important the Google
partnership and the Google Apps are for
us and for our users today so we live in
a space where project management has
kind of been left to the 2% of the
people that understand project
management principles and as we
understand calendaring and other stuff
we're that way five years ago so as the
work is transforming smartsheet provides
18,000 new processes or projects to
their users every day so it's a growing
world where people realize that they
don't have a tool to do the things they
need to do so what we are is
collaborative work management
collaborative work management basically
comes to this place where we had project
management software in the past but we
were really using Excel or spreadsheets
and email to solve a problem which was I
got to gather data from people we got to
talk about it we got to share it we got
to go through it but then we didn't do
anything with it we sort of were dead
ended there and now the number of apps
for that's happening whether it's sort
of legacy IT apps or other apps that
people are using is increasing in volume
and then the number of places that they
are connecting whether that's all
through G suite or a hundred other
products that are all best to breed is
increasing as well so the number of
vectors that you have to cover for all
of your users is going up as well and so
as we look at this place and this is
happening now because users are doing
more stuff all the time online the
velocity is going up so we're living in
a world where these three V's are
causing us as administrators or as
developers or whichever audience we're
in to have to deal with this but in
order for our users to be delighted and
actually want to come to work every day
we have to provide them with great tools
and the great tools have to work
together so these are some of our stats
over the Google partnership that we've
had and we've enjoyed a really strong
partnership with them for the last four
years but I want to talk a little more
about what the important thing is so nan
talked about picking an app and so when
you go to pick an app in the modern
workforce we really believe that you
need to pick something that's used
by all teams in the company so it's not
enough to just deploy a project
management solution and hope your five
project managers can cover your 200
person company you have to cross
boundaries you have to be able to share
internally and externally you have to
integrate all key apps and everybody has
to be satisfied that means security
needs they need to be there that means
your control needs to be there but at
the same time you really have to show
users that they have a product they can
use every day so that you empower them
to be better so what I wanted to do
before I talk to any more because people
are like what's smartsheet and what's
project management we put together a
little video about how we work with G
suite so you guys could kind of see a
real-world example that we do for our
users everyday marchi is the leading
fast platform for managing and
automating collaborative work thousands
of the world's most productive companies
and millions of information workers trap
smartsheet to help them work better
smartsheet scalable platforms is easy to
use and configure for a variety of high
value use cases smartsheet is
recommended for G Suites and integrates
with Google Apps and services to see
this in action let's look at how a
company uses smartsheet in Google to
accelerate service delivery and delight
customers
loop's manages a sales team he has a
forecast review meeting later today so
he checks the pipeline sheets to prepare
Luke sees he's at risk of missing his
forecast because a new services
engagement hasn't been assigned yet and
isn't included in his numbers for the
quarter he assigns a project to Janette
and make sure the services delivery
takes place before the end of the
quarter luke sheet automatically
publishes the delivery dates to Google
Calendar for additional visibility into
the deals timing Jeannette receives an
email notification about the new
assignment and logs into smartsheet with
her Google account to view the details
she sees that the project has a tight
timeline and immediately starts to hang
out with crisp the services engineer to
get more information
first responds and updates Jeannette
with information from a recent customer
call about the scope of the work he also
attaches a PDF of the Esso W document
you saved in Google Drive to the project
chief so that everyone working on the
project can access
Genet enter hang out with Chris and
updates the project status Mike the VP
of Sales reviews of team's performance
and feeds his team is rocking and ahead
of planned making him and his customer a
fan for life that is real no it's not
real but to that point you sell a lot of
integrations and there it goes through
quickly but we have over 15 points of
integration with G suite and part of us
being in the G suite marketplace and
really being a recommended app we
believe that it's important for all of
our Google users to be able to work with
us every day and as you noticed that was
a seamless workflow through the
organization where you dropped in and
out of different tools through Gmail and
calendar but nobody needed to know that
what was happening was that smartsheet
was behind the scenes driving some of
the work automation and work management
so to that end I wanted to talk about
how we think about this space
so traditionally project management has
been sort of to the single person and as
we look at process management work
automation and the things that we used
to always do by emailing around
spreadsheets there's a bunch of things
that we can make better and that's by
doing better tracking and so today we
have that with Gmail for our contact
lists we can start a hangout directly
from smartsheet we can report better so
we can actually merge info from
smartsheet to power a mail merge in Docs
for a small business so if you have
somebody that says hey I have an address
list it's in a spreadsheet import it
from sheets use the mail merge
functionality and you generate a bunch
of documents it's a fairly simple
integration that can be done every day
then on the automation front we can
bring data directly from sheets into
smartsheet and we can send update to
request via Gmail and fill them out in
the form we also do single sign-on we're
working right now on skim so you can do
user provisioning and de-provisioning
directly from Google and you can create
and attach and view sheets to Google
Drive and restrict it to Google Drive so
that you can get full management
capability throughout the app from
Google and using smartsheet so it
becomes a very easy way for you to
control the data that goes in there and
you have a lot of controls for it coming
out but at the same time the users get a
seamless
experience with both smartsheet and
working with Google I casino bus
so one of the big customers that we had
was a sort of former Microsoft Project
customer and migrated over to Google and
today they're actually a large scale
manufacturing software business but
essentially they came by and said with
Google Apps with workday and with
smartsheet we have transformed our
entire business from a legacy stack so
eliminated Microsoft Project that was a
hole in a marketplace or a hole in their
operation after they flipped over but
also to do other things which throughout
human resources finances and sales
they're using us every day from employee
onboarding to actual tracking of their
sales team so it really allows a
powerful work management experience
throughout the app but again it does all
this stuff while working with the Google
Apps that they're using every day so the
learning curve gets smaller and the
deployment gets easier so as we talk
about transforming work is a very lofty
solution one of the things that we've
been talking a lot about is that we have
to empower everybody to do automation
and due process and get to those things
on their own and as you guys have a
large user base so you have a set of
people that you're supporting every day
it's really important to remember that
they are not technical and so we're
throwing more and more apps at them
every day and every time they have to
learn a new paradigm and that's great
when it's snapchat and Facebook and it's
fun to do on your phone it's not great
when you have to come to work and you
can't get your work done and so it's
really important that we do that and
continue to do that we have more
intelligence now today with with AI
empowering those things so we should
make our apps better and the thing that
I keep telling people is we did a user
study recently and our users said when
the word if appeared on screen that it
was too programmer e it was too hard to
use the word if and a construct they
wanted the word when and the reason I
bring that up is all these developers
and everybody else is saying I can teach
these people to be citizen developers
but I think that's the wrong thing I
think we need to support them in using
lots of apps and I think we need to do
it to make work better so what I'm
hoping and what I'm hoping more people
in the room sort of attach to and build
for is let's agree to delight our users
whether that's giving them the apps they
want
or managing the app so they don't see
what's going on behind the scenes
let's get apps to talk together without
cut copy and paste one of our biggest
use cases for dashboard is the
elimination of PowerPoint because what
people want to see is real-time
dashboards of projects and they don't
want to copy and paste them out of a
spreadsheet that they roll up that they
put in there and spend an hour each week
so find the things that you can do to
support your users every day so they can
spend less time doing those sorts of
things and then find the things that
they don't know they don't know so as we
talk about all this artificial
intelligence and other things that we
can use to support our product our users
let's use AI to make their life better
not let's use our AI to surface ten
times more information and so my
challenge to all these people that are
supporting other all their customers
every day is let's make work better not
because we're going to make you know we
have a lot more technology but let's
make it better so that people are more
effective and so to that end we've
announced at this conference that we are
working on the hangouts of hangouts chat
which is the hangouts v2 to go with our
hangouts v1 integration we're also
looking at Google now to make it easier
to input data into our system and at the
same time we're going to invest heavy
and machine learning not to sort of
predict where people are going but to
help them find the features that they
don't have and so as we look forward to
innovation as we look forward to doing
more things with Google and supporting
you guys in building better products we
really look to making a great product
but using the power of technology and
innovating on the way our users can
consume it it needs to be much easier
for users to do the hard things that we
want them to do so they can be more
effective so if you want to see us we'll
be down at booth D to Joe's a the
manager of our Google lines we've got
other folks down there feel free to come
by get a demo or just sort of learn a
little more about smartsheet and theirs
thank you and I'm handing it off to
prosper works
thank you Andy hi everyone I'm Tara
lengthy and I'm here with my colleague
Jesse price and we are with prosper
works which is a CRM that's
purpose-built 4G suite we're super
excited to be here today the event has
been awesome and we're thrilled to have
the opportunity to tell you guys a
little bit about prosper works and how
we're helping our customers be more
successful but first I want to address a
question that I think a clicker but I
think some of you have had either
consciously or subconsciously as I've
been talking today which is um oh we go
really another CRM there's a lot of CRM
s out there we know so what could
possibly be so great or so unique or so
different about prospered so I think
that's a really valid question and I
want to spend a few minutes answering it
for you guys and telling you why we're
here and the problem that we're really
trying to solve so when you ask people
about their experience with their CRM
you typically don't get any warm and
fuzzies they're not positive responses
you get people that are really
frustrated saying things like I hate it
it's a pain in the you-know-what it's
clunky it's way too complicated it
really doesn't help me do my job any
better or faster or easier it honestly
just requires a boatload of work and
time and effort from me and I really
don't feel like I'm getting anything in
return and so because of that people
just don't use it and that's a really
big problem it's a problem because your
CRM every business needs a CRM it's a
mission-critical tool for your business
and it's not just there to collect all
your data and manage all of your
contacts in one place it's there to
really give you visibility and insights
and the data you need to make smarter
decisions that will help you move your
business forward and if people aren't
using your CRM you're not going to get
any of that value out of it
so that's the problem that we are
solving we're building we built a CRM
that actually gives users more than it
takes we're good we're building a CRM
that is really really easy to use so not
only your team will use it but when
they're using it they love using it they
want to use it and we're doing it by
removing all the things that really suck
about all the other CRM which is manual
data entry and annoying tedious
repetitive tasks that are super
time-consuming and we're making it super
intuitive and beautiful and really easy
to use and we're integrating it with the
tools that you already know and love so
that it's seamlessly a part of your
existing processes and work flow so
we're solving a really really hard
problem that no crm has been able to
solve before which is the adoption and
usability problem and we think Google
Bree agrees with our approach so we are
the number one recommended CRM and the G
suite marketplace we won Google's best
new technology last year we're the first
partner to build on Google slides API
and we're one of the first people who
are able to build the Gmail add-on that
was announced yesterday which is very
exciting and even some of Google's teams
are actually using prosper works which
is awesome so it's not just Google
that's validated this problem that we're
solving and agrees with us is something
important we have 75,000 users who love
Fross works and I'm going to pass it
over to Jesse who's going to tell you
how you're using cross works and the
value that were providing them today
all right thanks Kyra and thanks for
attending the session excited to be here
today so I've got a great job I'm the
director of sales at prosper work and
that means that I get to spend a lot of
time with our customers understanding
their businesses and really helping them
solve this the CRM challenge and just to
echo what sharor has been speaking about
you know I don't know when but at some
point CRM just got really hard you know
it became really complex it gives the
users
anxiety when they think about logging in
and making their updates and so people
just don't use it
and so from a product standpoint you
know prosper works really think about
that CRM journey really getting control
of your your customer data in a few
different ways number one that's helping
teams become hyper organized knowing
where data is having easy access to that
data being able to follow up on time
with every lead and make the most of
that and number two is once you're
organized it's really about being able
to establish those processes in your
business but make it super easy for
maybe a new rep to follow or someone
who's not as well versed with sales
process you know really kind of take
your behaviors these senior a players
make it super easy for the rest of the
team to follow those and then the last
part is really having the insights to
optimize those processes over time so
you want to constantly improve your
business and make sure that you know
every quarter every year you're doing
better so one of our customers / Joe
who's a French car manufacturer you may
have heard of how this exact problem
with adoption among some they deal is in
one of the Asia offices where people
were not using their existing CRM
reverting to paper notes speaking notes
spreadsheets which is really not helpful
from a company standpoint having
visibility of what people are talking
about with their customers and means
that a lot of people aren't following up
as well which is they kind of lose these
these pieces of paper and so forth
and so we migrated into G suite with one
of our partners in the Asia region and
put CRM right inside of Gmail so using a
Chrome extension that we built really
closely with Google able to basically
take your CRM data and put it right in
front of we you users spend the majority
of their time which is inside of gmail
calendar and other Google of G suite
applications like sheets and slides
hangouts and so forth so we're able to
basically give you context over that
last interaction that you had with your
customer or maybe give you the contact
details that you need to reach out but
you're making updates in real time and
aren't being sort of asked to then log
into a different application and
to make those changes at the end of the
day which let me tell you a lot of
people just don't through so in terms of
that context and accessibility of your
CRM information you know we think it's
really important has that in Gmail but
it's also really important to have that
on your cell phone you know we carry
these things everywhere that we go and
being able to make those updates from
the road is really important and I think
that our customer local roots has a
really great example of that
so what these guys do is they pioneered
a way to essentially grow a food farm
inside of a shipping container which is
pretty cool solving the world's food
shortage problems using these really
innovative highly mobile farms that can
produce a lot of food really quickly and
they coordinate these deliveries from a
few satellite offices around the world
with a highly mobile workforce and with
mobile apps are able to quickly make
updates within an uber or if they're you
know on their way to the airport waiting
for a plane and have real-time
information about these shipments and
deliveries right right there in their
pocket and as Kure mentioned before you
know something else is really exciting
from a mobile standpoint is that we are
now able to integrate CRM data straight
into your Gmail app on your phone
through the Gmail add-on that we
announced yesterday we also have another
mobile add-on for Google sheets so that
I can refresh my sales data from inside
of my Google sheets app for my cell
phone as well and I really can this is
exciting for the future of mobile apps
where they're not just standalone
applications anymore but they're
integrated and able to tie in together
so just to recap you know talking about
organization being really important
having access to data the next step is
really creating those processes so
looking at you eight players on your
team and being able to make a path that
is really easy for the other people in
the company to follow to get the same
results so we use very visual pipelines
what you can see in the graphic there is
that it's really clean we've used
material design across all of our
platforms that web mobile chrome
extension you name it makes it really
easy for people to adopt and learn
how to use the CRM in this example the
reason I like this example is that our
customer love your melon another sales
organization there are not-for-profit
who are selling beanies mittens other
clothing items and using all of those
proceeds to really contribute to an
important cause which is battling cancer
among children in the US so they use
these pipelines not for a sales process
but to essentially cordon a truly
complex recruiting events on university
campuses around the states and it really
is easy for those sort of non-technical
college students to follow the process
that's laid out in front of them and to
organize these great events now once
your teams are organized and following
the right processes as I mentioned
before it's really important to
constantly improve your business and be
able to tweak and optimize these
processes over time and so we have a
really easy use set of reports in the
system that don't require to you to you
know hire a business analyst or know how
to create really complex queries it's
all very visual very kind of
drag-and-drop click orientated if you
will so that any business user can
really embrace that data and look for
opportunities to improve those those
outcomes so issues are a really great in
tech startup in the Bay Area and they're
growing like crazy and they just brought
on a new VP of Sales Band who we work
closely with and you know the feedback
we got from Ben that he was just blown
away about really quickly was how easy
it is to adapt Croft works to his sales
process if not asked his team to adapt
to the CRM and that was really important
to them because when he came on board
they were using a legacy CRM obviously
no one was really keeping the data up to
date and so as a new VP of Sales very
difficult to build a sales plan
understand how many people you should be
hiring in what time frame
so if this all sounds really great to
you guys and you know you're kind of
interested in thinking like well that's
cool but what's it take to set up I've
tried implementing CRM before and it's
really difficult it's really expensive
and it it was a failure
rest assured just like the rest of our
kind of design philosophy and ease of
use getting started is super easy as
well so what we're able to do is when
you log in through your Gmail account we
can basically analyze your inbox and
start to suggest people that you may
want to add to the system based on the
patterns of email activity that you've
had with these people in the past so
it's great because it surfaces the right
data for your organization you're not
kind of forced to you know ship in a
pile of data from a system that wasn't
working previously and kind of move
those problems to a new platform what's
also great is that when you add these
people to the system we're going to go
out and research them for you so we'll
find things like their company
information how many employees they have
where they're located let's give you
some links to their social profiles so
you can see what's relevant to them what
they've been sweating about and that
says our users tons of time so if you
look at the sales team there's you know
30 40 50 people or going out and
collecting that information on a per
contact basis this is a massive time
saver and a really great experience for
the user when they are sort of surprised
and delighted by the information we can
surface for them now in addition to
getting your data into the system all
the configuration is basically clicks
and not code so that you don't have to
reach out to an expensive consultant as
you may have been used to doing in the
past and to get started we go to team
who can help with that and we really
want to empower you as the business user
to get to make these administration
changes without having to once again
make a phone call and wait a week in
order to update a custom field or to
tweak your sales process based on
something that's happening in the
marketplace
so to recap you know you know in our
view CRM is about helping teams be hyper
organized
helping you teens follow-up having
access to data from within the apps that
you are using today which is things like
gmail calendar sheets slides having
access and mobile apps and so the
integration of now you're G suite
applications and applications like
prosper works or a mobile standpoint as
well being able to implement process
that anybody can follow regardless of
how well birth they are in CRM we're in
business process management themselves
and just make it very visual very easy
to engage with and then finally having
those analytics and insights to really
improve those processes as business and
make sure your results are always
getting better so it's back to you Kara
great cool so we've been talking about
you guys for like 10 minutes now so if
there's anything we want you to take
away from hearing from Jessie and I it's
that prosper works is the CRM the team's
actually love to use and it's because
it's purpose-built 4G suite it sits
right in your inbox it's super intuitive
it works on any device and you can get
up and running in a matter of days or
even hours so if you're interested in
learning more you can visit us
downstairs in booth e to today or of
course you can go to our website prosper
works calm thanks for listening and I'm
going to invite uh none back up to give
some final parting words before we dig
into the Q&A session thank you
[Applause]
getting this stay up cool
well we'll jump right into Q&A but just
final call to action go visit GC
Marketplace GC Google calm or there's a
nifty tool called Google to search
seafood marketplace
[Music]
you
[Music]